it's a startling visual reminder of the
power of paper and pen fierce clashes
this week left many concerns their
message was being eclipsed by violence
but step away from the protest
frontlines and the scale of peaceful
dissent becomes clear this train station
now an ever-growing testimony to the
resilience of activists and the people
power that fuels them when you walk
through this tunnel the [ __ ] number of
messages papering these walls is really
overwhelming note after note urging
these protesters to carry on what the
protest movement now needs to work out
is how to maintain momentum and this
level of support over the coming weeks
just 15 years old this young activist is
choosing post-it notes and posters as
her new weapon of protest once on the
frontlines of the demonstrations herself
she now spends up to 8 hours a day here
holding her own private vigil promoting
her pro-democracy message I would like
to do the thing that I think it is quite
I think it is very important in this
time to just let the government know
it's what we require for
to tell you we will never give up across
the city a very different kind of
protest calls have been put out for
people to withdraw all their money from
bank accounts a peaceful but perhaps
ambitious plan designed to put pressure
on authorities to meet their demands
Hong Kong people have tried many
different way to try to ask Hong Kong
government to withdraw the extradition
bill we just want to try every mean
every possible means to stop the bill
massive street protests like this are
still planned over the coming days and
weeks
some may end in clashes but this
movement has been defined by its
inventiveness the protesters ability to
evolve their strategy to maintain
momentum and public support and
alongside the demonstrations there will
be those he'll keep finding new ways of
making their voices heard and the WHL at
gelsin Pill joins us now from Hong Kong
Basheer's Charlotte some some real
determination we've seen there from the
young activists tell us what the
situation is right now and yeah some
protesters are back on the streets today
it's been a very rainy day so far in
Hong Kong I'm sure you can see all the
people behind me carrying umbrellas but
they're braving this really horrible
weather at multiple different locations
across Hong Kong today earlier we saw
teachers protests this now is an
anti-government protest in tandem
another protest is taking place across
the city in support of the government
now this protest here has been
authorized but police have said very
clearly that people are not allowed to
stray from the permitted route but what
we have seen so many times over the last
few weeks and yeah is that these
protesters do do spread they do break
those police rules and occasionally yes
they do end in clashes okay now a
chinese state media editorial this week
stated that if cheung-kong can't restore
rule of law on its own it will it is
quote imperative for the central
government to take direct action now
what does statements like that suggest
what effect are they having on the
protesters clearly they're a big cause
of concern for people who are on the
streets here that ramped up rex rhetoric
is is happening in tandem with images
that we're seeing of the palamoun
paramilitary People's Armed Police who
are taking part in exercises along the
border very very close from hit to here
so people that are concerned although
most people that we've spoke to don't
think that they are going to see
imminently any troops from Beijing on
the streets of Hong Kong people here
believe that that is going to be to
higher cost for Beijing both politically
and economically they believe that
Beijing has other ways of getting these
protesters and these protests under
control like for example putting
pressure on authorities here to make
sure they clamp down and we have heard
from police in the last few days that
they say that they can keep these
protests under control protesters here
though deeply concerned about what that
may mean they say that police are
becoming increasingly heavy-handed in
dealing with these protests as they go
on into the evening all right Charlotte
Sheldon field reporting for us from Hong
Kong thanks so much